YouTube are gonna ban your ad blocker or
at least they are toying with the idea
of doing so they have been testing some
potential anti-adblocker Solutions
similar to how twitch does things this
is naturally going to make a lot of
folks mad but how do I a YouTube Creator
feel about this whole thing well It's
tricky because here's the thing not only
do people make their livings off of
YouTube's AdSense Revenue now but the
entire platform itself sustains itself
off of that hosting and serving millions
of minutes of new footage per minute is
an incomprehensibly expensive task but
at the same time I mean let's be honest
YouTube ads are very annoying it's one
thing when there's a few ads in a long
video so what is the right answer here
well I don't really know I literally pay
my bills with AdSense Revenue so
naturally I'm inclined to be more
accepting of a change like this but I
really do think there is something to be
said about how increasingly pervasive
and intrusive YouTube ads have gotten
over the years so I don't know